[Music]
on this tuesday night troublesome
new trends kobit 19 is spreading through
communities at an alarming rate in
canada's largest city
who is most at risk more public health
measures are needed
plus new concerns about kovid 19 in
alberta's capital
the uncertain future of newfoundland and
labrador's only oil refinery
the call there is what am i going to do
fresh criticism of the american
president his misleading tweet as the
virus spreads
to the pentagon and a somber goodbye
to the golden boy of canadian politics
we need more people like john
the state funeral for former prime
minister john turner
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after all the warnings about a second
wave of covid19 this fall
some regions in canada are not prepared
for it there are not enough tests
not enough labs and not enough contact
tracers and the virus is spreading
through some communities at an alarming
rate
quebec had a record high number of new
covid19 cases today
the health minister there says it's too
many to trace and they don't know where
people are getting infected
in toronto there are reports more than
10 percent of tests in some
neighborhoods
are coming back positive that means
uncontrolled communities spread
abigail beeman has our top story tonight
federal health officials say if a
community's positive test rate is higher
than
5 percent it's a problem there's new
data showing in some pockets of toronto
the rate tops 10 percent that's where we
we have to focus on
we we go out there we put the mobile
testing units up
we get more advertising within those
communities that is very concerning
those rates are high and those are
neighborhoods
and areas that we already knew we're at
increased risk
based on other data increased risk with
a high number of racialized and
low-income residents
it's very alarming because of course you
know the report is around specific
neighborhoods in toronto but we know
that people don't just stay in their
neighborhood and it is an indication
that more public health measures are
needed while toronto's top doctor has
been calling for tougher measures the
premier isn't budging on closing
restaurants
you can't put people out of work tens of
thousands of people destroy their lives
just like bang that quickly meanwhile
doug ford says they're making progress
on the testing backlog reducing it by 40
percent
as of tuesday all centers moved to
appointment only
but trying to book a test in toronto is
a challenge with each hospital on a
different booking system
and many full we are adding to the
lineup
of rapid tests that we have procured
health canada has now approved the first
antigen test the abbot pan bio the
government is buying up to 20.5 million
this type of technology is not as good
as the pcr based test
but it doesn't mean it doesn't have
certain advantages abbott's own website
says the pan bio provides
preliminary results and can't be used as
the only basis for
treatment but its advantages include
being faster and easier to use it's the
test ford keeps calling a game changer
ottawa says it's valuable in isolated
areas
and its strategy around rapid testing
means using them to supplement
not replace traditional ones abigail
beeman
global news ottawa the federal
government says more than 8 million of
those rapid tests will be distributed
across canada by the end of this year
here is where we are at
today quebec reported more than 1300 new
covid19 cases that is the most in a
single day
in ontario more than 540 people tested
positive
alberta recorded 276 new cases today
and b.c just over 100 alberta's chief
medical officer is sounding the alarm
warning tighter public restrictions
could be imposed because community
transmission is getting out of control
in edmonton many people are ignoring the
rules and not self-isolating while they
wait for test results
and as heather urex west reports active
cases in alberta are now the highest
they've been
in nearly five months at 50 percent
capacity with no
weddings or large events it's been a
summer of treading
water for this edmonton restaurant but
its owner says
they've managed to adapt so far to be
able to
do that and then now have to consider
going back to where we were
and having to pivot again and find
another way to
you know keep going through takeout and
delivery and those sort of things
it's scary for the first time this fall
alberta's chief medical health
officer is warning new restrictions may
be coming in edmonton
since the beginning of september alberta
has managed to keep its curve
relatively flat but a surge over the
weekend
is raising concern over what's to come
we have seen an escalation of cases in
edmonton
an increase in the reproductive number
to 1.3 last week
and a rise in active cases what's behind
the spike
is under investigation but health
officials say it's clear
that not everyone is following
guidelines one alarming trend we have
seen in our review of current
active cases is about 11 percent
of cases are attending work or still
going to social gatherings when
symptomatic while awaiting test results
part of the problem a backlog at alberta
labs means it's taking up to
five days at times to turn covid19 test
results around
cases are expected to increase in the
coming days but the real test will
likely come
after the thanksgiving weekend if we
have a high case number in the community
the risk of having spread our events at
these social gatherings goes up
dramatically
not good news for business owners hoping
to avoid another shutdown
as alberta inches closer to its second
wave
heather urex west global news calgary
british columbia is in a better position
the provincial public health officer
says the covid curve there is flattening
and for the first time since the summer
the transmission rate is manageable but
as robin gill explains now is not the
time to widen your social circle
one of the worst outbreaks in british
columbia is on the second floor of delta
hospital
in a suburb of vancouver 18 patients and
17 staff members have tested positive
some of those health care workers
brought covid into the hospital
any health care worker who was in the
community
risks picking up the infection and
bringing it to work where
of course their patients are impacted if
there's some consolation
for every person infected with covet 19
in bc
they've passed it on to less than one
person so there's no
exponential exposure according to the
province's public health officer
that's a key factor right now we're
keeping our curve
flat and low compared to many other
places
but we are not out of the woods compared
to other provinces
bc has a tighter reign on the virus take
a look between september 21st and
october 4th
bc's total cases were just under 1500
compare that to ontario which had over 7
500 cases
in that two-week period but quebec's
numbers spiked
over 10 000 cases in the same time frame
we've done the right things and people
in bc have taken the measures that we
need
those measures include shutting down
nightclubs and banquet halls in early
september
to prevent large gatherings most people
in bc are keeping their bubbles to about
45 percent of their social network
people have made tremendous sacrifices
in terms of their work
in terms of their education in terms of
their social activities
and that's what it's going to take to
continue keeping this thing under
control
these are universal sacrifices because
people are still dying from covet 19.
seven people with this horrific disease
spent their last moments
at delta hospital robin gill global news
vancouver
quebec's premier apologized to the
family of joyce eshequan today
she is the indigenous woman who recorded
hospital staff taunting her and making
degrading comments as she pleaded for
help
she died soon after joyce
ishaquan quebec's national assembly held
a moment of silence today for the 37
year old she died september 28
at the hospital in joliet the way she
was treated led to widespread calls for
action against systemic racism
her family is suing the hospital today
premier lago said quebec's public
service failed in its duty and he
promised change to avoid
others being mistreated the way she was
the future of newfoundland's only oil
refinery hangs in the balance tonight
the 50 year old facility and come by
chance was going to be sold to irving
oil but that deal
has fallen through the newfoundland
government and hundreds of workers had
hoped it would give
new life to the old refinery there's
talk another company is interested but
as ross lord reports
nothing seems certain in the industry
right now
fortune smiled on workers at
newfoundland's come by chance oil
refinery when they won
a lottery jackpot worth 60 million
dollars
31 millionaires from newfoundland and
labrador
two years later the refinery's 500
workers fear their luck might have run
out
they're crying and they're upset and
some people are saying
is there hope already reeling from
production being halted since april
they're facing the prospect of the
refinery being closed
permanently talks between the owner
north atlantic and a buyer irving oil
have collapsed the call there is what am
i going to do
uh you know where am i going to get a
job what's you know
there's no work out there the next thing
is what about my benefits like i need
health benefits for my kids
i need for my wife or i need it for my
husband of course the pandemic's impact
on oil and gas goes beyond newfoundland
and labrador
in alberta suncor just announced plans
to lay off up to 2
000 people in the house of commons the
opposition leader pressed the government
about job losses in both provinces
that's 2500 working families that are
wondering how they're going to pay
for groceries mr speaker when is this
government going to have a real plan
for energy workers and their families
during this pandemic
over 1 million albertans have received
the serb
of a population of 4.3 million that is
nearly
one quarter of albertans the government
says it's provided 320 million dollars
for the energy industry in newfoundland
and labrador
that province's liberal government says
it's not giving up income by chance
although negotiations are between
private companies
in a statement north atlantic says it
will not be providing comment on
internal confidential matters the union
says most of its members have been laid
off since the spring and those remaining
will be laid off
immediately there is some hope another
possible buyer from the u.s has
expressed interest
leaving open the possibility that a
permanent closure might still be
avoided ross lord global news
canada's biggest oil producing province
hit hard by a drop in demand is taking
steps to diversify its resource-based
economy by becoming an exporter
of hydrogen a clean burning fuel as an
energy source hydrogen produces zero
emissions
and has greater potential to power
not just appliances but also heavy duty
transportation
and electricity generation alberta
premier jason kenney unveiled his
province's new natural gas strategy
today which includes ambitions to ramp
up the production and export of
liquefied natural gas
finance and investment firms predict the
global hydrogen industry
could be worth 2.5 trillion dollars u.s
annually by 2050
and he also wants to move towards what's
called a plastic circular economy
becoming a hub for reducing plastic
through new recycling initiatives
without reducing production of the
material
michelle obama no holds barred coming up
her blunt message
to american voters
the former american first lady michelle
obama has released a video message
called closing argument
she makes the case for why american
voters should choose joe biden
over donald trump the one thing this
president
is really really good at is using fear
and confusion and spreading lies to win
obama was first lady while joe biden was
vice president and she says he has the
heart the experience and the character
to lead
and that the drama of the past few days
has only emphasized what's at stake in
this election from the coronavirus to a
constant drumbeat of fear
division and chaos that's threatening to
spiral out of control
they're stoking fears about black and
brown americans
lying about how minorities will destroy
the suburbs
whipping up violence and intimidation
and they're pinning it all on what's
been an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement for
racial solidarity
what the president is doing is once
again
patently false it's morally wrong
and yes it is racist
but that doesn't mean it won't work
michelle obama also said her heart goes
out to all the people who work behind
the scenes at the white house the secret
service and residence staff whose names
and stories she says
will never know the virus continues to
spread today stephen miller the
president's senior policy advisor tested
positive
also the top u.s general along with
other senior military staff at the
pentagon announced they are in
self-isolation
the white house cleaning staff wore
hazmat suits to sanitize the press
briefing room at the white house
and there's an update on the president's
health according to his doctor trump had
a restful night
and has no symptoms today as jackson
proskow reports trump seems intent on
putting on a show of strength
knowing the election is less than a
month away
unmoved by his own experience with the
virus an emboldened and likely still
infectious president trump has embraced
full-on denialism
don't let it dominate you don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
in a morning tweet
trump went further exaggerating the
death toll of the seasonal flu and
suggesting we have learned to live with
it
and should do the same with covet 19. a
sign he plans to portray himself as a
strong man against a pandemic that has
killed 210
000 americans we have essentially
politics
infecting our public's health this is a
disaster for public health in general
it's also now a national security threat
at the pentagon
seven senior military leaders including
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff
are in quarantine after their own
exposure several of them had been at the
white house for this maskless indoor
ceremony on september 27th
the day after that now infamous rose
garden event
there are more cases coming out of the
white house these days than
in entire other countries and that's
simple because
we're not choosing to fight this and
democrat choosing to accommodate it
incredibly the white house with all its
resources has refused to undertake
contact tracing or notification
even as cases now spike in washington
d.c
the administration is also refusing to
give any information about the
president's
own history of testing if we need to be
taking samples those
swabs that have diagnosed them as
positive have
very important information that could
tell us exactly how this virus was
introduced
into the white house and that genetic
information could
could be used to explain exactly
who transmitted it to whom
the president's defiance of the virus
comes as polls show him slipping even
further behind joe biden one survey out
today has him
16 points behind at the same time though
there's still a strategy to try and
carry on with the presidential debates
the president says
he will travel to the next one although
there's likely to be a squabble over
debate preventative measures surrounding
covid19
tomorrow's vice presidential debate has
already descended into a bit of a
squabble
over whether or not the candidate should
be protected behind plexiglas screens
donna okay lots to come jackson prosco
in washington thanks
ahead devils are back down under for the
first time
in centuries
canada is calling for an end to days of
deadly fighting between armenia and
azerbaijan
canada and the uk issued a joint
statement today saying we urge all
external parties and friends of both
states to redouble their efforts
in support of an end to hostilities and
to refrain from taking actions that risk
exacerbating the crisis
turkey has been accused of supplying
drones and combatants to its ally
azerbaijan as it battles armenian and
separatist forces in the disputed
breakaway region of nagorno-karabakh
turkey accuses canada of a double
standard it points to canada's 14
billion dollar deal to supply light
armored vehicles to saudi arabia
which has been waging a five-year war in
yemen
for the first time in 3 000 years the
tasmanian devil
is back on mainland australia last month
actor chris
hemsworth helped conservationists
release this pair of tasmanian devils at
a sanctuary
26 of the animals have been reintroduced
to an area north of
sydney dingoes drove the devils to
tasmania and then in the 1990s cancer
wiped out about 90 percent
of the population only about 25 000
tasmanian devils are alive in the wild
today
well 2020 just sucks eddie van halen the
legendary guitar player and innovator
has died
he was just 65 he had been treated for
throat cancer
through five decades and three lead
singers he played with all his heart and
inspired generations of guitarists his
son said today
every moment with his dad on stage and
off was a gift
former canadian prime minister john
turner was honored with a state funeral
today though the pandemic
meant it was a modified low-key affair
with a limited number of mourners
prime minister justin trudeau was there
and he recalled how turner who died last
week at the age of 91
had said democracy doesn't happen by
accident
eric sorenson on the tributes to john
turner
[Music]
the canadian flag and an escort of
mounties an image
so befitting a man admired above all
else for his love of country
john turner's funeral brought
dignitaries from his days in politics
friends he'd had for life and family
jill's to whom he was married for 57
years
we have lost our northern star to his
daughter elizabeth turner set an example
with his dignity
friends spoke of the great outdoorsmen
his generosity
his humor when john heard people
complain about the weather
he would say come on are you a tourist
or a canadian
justin trudeau has known john turner
since he was a child
today more than ever we need more people
like john
his legacy calls on us not to wait for
change to happen
but to stand up and build a better
country
for everyone we'll carry our share of
the load and we will
john turner seemed destined for
leadership he was charismatic
he'd qualified for the olympics and was
a rhodes scholar
as a young lawyer he had a relationship
with princess margaret that seemed
briefly
serious he turned to politics recruited
by lester pearson's liberals
then served in the cabinet of another
rising star pierre trudeau
for turner politics was an honorable
calling to build a better nation
i've avoided what i like to call
cosmetic politics
the type of politics that look good in
the short term but wouldn't be
good for the country after a dispute
with trudeau over campaign promises
turner left politics for almost a decade
but then came back for the job
he'd always wanted turner one
thousand eight hundred and sixty-two
turner
he out dueled jean-critician for the
liberal leadership and in 1984 became
canada's
17th prime minister it lasted 79 days
patronage appointments left to him by
trudeau led to a defining blow by brian
mulroney in an election debate
you had an option sir you could have
said i am not going to do it this is
wrong for canada
may i congratulate mr mulroney the
liberals suffered one of their worst
electoral defeats
in the next election he tried again
debating free trade
i happen to believe that you've sold us
out a champion of canadian sovereignty
turner would not however win back the
job of prime minister
over the years i've found that the
goodbyes in this place are far more
generous and spontaneous than the hello
democracy does not happen by accident
become
involved get out there
get something back
state funerals are rare but this was
unique in the time of covet 19
so many more would have wished to be
here to honor a man who did indeed
give something back
[Music]
the funeral of john turner that is
global national for this tuesday i'm
donna friesen tonight's your canada is
near maycroft in southwestern alberta
there are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye